- [Zac] In 1983, the girl known as Eleven
opened the gates to the Upside Down.
While this led to the temporary
disappearance of Will Byers
and the death of Barbara Holland,
the most dangerous and impactful thing
that opening the gate did
was allow the Mind Flayer
to access the human world.
The Mind Flayer takes on an abstract form,
often described as a shadow or a storm,
even being referred to
as the shadow monster,
like many characters
from "Stranger Things"
it's most likely exists as an allegory
for the communist leadership
that existed in Russia at the time.
And we'll get into how its
behavior reflects that.
When the Mind Flayer enters
the Right Side Up world of Hawkins,
it may be the biggest threat that the town
has ever encountered.
LUCAS: We're talking about
the destruction of our world
as we know it
- To learn more about the Mind Flayer
and its connections to the
ideology of the Soviet Union,
stick around to the end of this video.
(dramatic upbeat music)
Welcome to "Horror History."
The Mind Flayer did not
initially or at least directly
affect the town of Hawkins Indiana in 1983
when the gates of the Upside
Down was first opened,
however roughly a year later, Will Byers
sees the Mind Flayer for the first time,
indicating its arrival to Hawkins.
Like the Demogorgon,
the Mind Flayer's name
originates from the manual
of the boys' favorite game,
Dungeons and Dragons.
This shadow monster
demonstrates many of the traits
explained in the D&D manual,
especially a tendency
towards a mind control
and being linked to its victims.
That all starts with Will.
So to fully understand
why the creature chose him
as its first victim,
I'm gonna have to take it all the way back
to Will's first visit to the Upside Down.
(dramatic upbeat music)
It is likely that Will Byers
becomes the Mind Flayer's first target
because Will was the first
person to go into the Upside Down
and come out alive.
This means that the Mind Flayer
could have already had
some familiarity with him.
I assume that it already
started infecting Will
in the Upside Down in November of 1983.
When he's found he has a
tentacle suctioned to his mouth
that they have to carefully remove.
The tentacle is not attached
to anything specific,
it's just kind of part of the Upside Down.
We've seen the Mind Flayer
or as I sometimes like
to call it to the MF,
take control of nearly every organism
found in these tunnels.
So it stands to reason
that it was already making
some sort of infection into Will.
Over Christmas that year
Will coughs up a slug
into a sink drain.
That later becomes a Demadog.
I did an episode of "Horror
History" on a Demodog as well.
Since the Mind Flayer
is essentially the leader of the Demodogs,
this means that it was
in fact the Mind Flayer
that made contact with Will in 1983.
On the night of October 28th, 1984
Will is enjoying playing at
the Arcade with his friends
when he's suddenly given a vision
that he's back in the Upside Down.
It's here that will actually sees the MF
for the first time partially
obscured by a dark cloud
filled with flashes of orange lightning.
Even though the Mind Flayer
hasn't technically flayed
or taken over it Will
yet, its connection to him
allows it to communicate its
intentions without words.
(upbeat music)
DR OWENS: What do you
think the evil wanted?
WILL: To kill you.
DR OWENS: To kill you?
WILL: Not me,
(suspenseful music)
everyone else.
- However, Will is only a small
part of the Mind Flares plan
to infiltrate Hawkins.
Dustin Henderson discovers
a new form of Demogorgon
which he coins as a Demodog.
The Mind Flayer's influence
over these creatures and Will
represents what's known as a hive mind
or a collective consciousness.
As a result any information that Will
or the Demodogs learn,
the Mind Flayer will know as well.
This is an analogy to
what went on in the USSR.
In my episode on Alexi,
I talked about how there
was constant surveillance
in the Soviet union
and its citizens were being monitored
to make sure they were
upholding communist ideals.
In the same way, the Mind
Flayer taps into the minds
of those who chooses to take control of
and keeps them under constant surveillance
which goes a long way to
helping it stay in power.
The Mind Flayer makes the Demodogs
dig a tunnel system under Hawkins.
The citizens are left completely unaware
of the Mind Flayers' existence
apart from a few farmers
who have land above the tunnel route
who noticed their pumpkins rot and die,
creating a lot of hostility between them.
The Mind Flayer continues
to reveal itself to Will
each time more vivid and more
aggressive than the last.
Will, an avid artist draws
what he sees in his visions
including a spider like
system of funnel clouds.
Then on Halloween, Will
opens up to his best friend,
Mike Wheeler about what he's seeing.
(upbeat music)
- No. It was like this
huge shadow in the sky.
Only it was alive.
It was coming for me
- The next day after school,
Will is again sent into a
vision of the Upside Down
as the Mind Flayer chases after him.
This time, even more
aggressively than before
resulting in this happening.
Will later explains
what happened to his mom
and describes the Mind Flayer
as more of a feeling.
WILL: I felt it everywhere.
I still feel it.
- The next day, he stays home from school
and appears to be sick.
But instead of running a fever
his temperature is extremely low.
This is a major trait of the
Mind Flayer who likes the cold
and wants to keep its human
host as chilly as possible.
This is probably another
part of the allegory
of the Mind Flayer being representative
of the Soviet Union and
Russia and the greater region
that the USSR had control over.
The climate in that part of the
world is absolutely freezing
by my sunny SoCal standards.
So it's very telling that the
creature feels most at home
when temperatures are low.
Will very bluntly
explains this when his mom
tries to draw him a bath.
WILL: No.
JOYCE: What?
WILL: He likes it cold
- Much like citizens under the USSR,
Will's individual
personality is being stifled
or hidden away under the Mind
Flayer's own personality.
Think of Will like a citizen
serving under his communist leader.
As Hopper and Mike come over
to the Byers house to help,
Will does his best to convey
what the MF is doing to him.
He describes sharing the
same thoughts and feelings
referring to them as his now memories.
They feel like memories, but
they take place in the present
rather than the past.
WILL: It's like he's reaching
into Hawkins more and more.
And the more he spreads the
more connected to him I feel.
- The mind Flayer would soon
face its first major threat
when Chief Hopper digs his
way into one of the veins
of the underground tunnel system
and catches a big surprise.
(dramatic upbeat music)
(slow music)
- [Zac] When Hopper infiltrates
the underground tunnels
one of the vines growing their sprays him.
"IN THE FACE"
- Causing him to collapse
and become vulnerable.
You know, I've used that clip before,
but I don't think it's
ever been more relevant.
However, the Mind Flayer
doesn't seek to flay Hopper
the way that it's Flayed Will.
Instead, as Will promised,
it just wants to kill him.
As Will and the others work to save him,
The Mind Flayer has another
set of issues to contend with.
Scientists at the Hawkins lab
conduct a test with the
soil that they collected
from the areas with rotting pumpkins.
They light a burner
under the infected soil
and causing a mini storm
similar to the one that Will
first saw the Mind Flayer in,
but this time on a much smaller scale.
This is another example of
the MF reacting negatively
to the heat, as MFs often do.
At the exact same time, we
see yet another example,
when a group of soldiers
burn off the tunnels
with a flame thrower.
Will's connection to the Mind Flayer
causes him to ride around in pain as well.
There's probably no image
in all of "Stranger Things"
that's more disturbing.
(will screaming)
After Will is rushed to the Hawkins lab,
he's sedated and that the pain subsides.
The Mind Flayer demonstrates
that Will no longer has much agency
when he barely recognizes
the people that he knows.
In other words, the Mind Flayer
is almost completely in control.
It makes Will tell the scientists
that the only way to stop it
is to send all the soldiers
to one specific place in
the underground tunnels.
But really it's just setting
up a huge trap to get revenge
on the soldiers that
brought it so much pain
with their flame throwers.
After this happens,
Mike realizes that Will
is essentially a spy
for the Mind Flayer.
The idea of a Russian spy
posing as an American citizen,
gives us another real world parallel.
The KGB was a Soviet security
and foreign intelligence agency in place
between the 1950s and the 1990s,
who controversially operated
as a secret police unit
in the Soviet Union.
They also sent spies to
integrate in other countries
like the United States to get information
on those who may oppose
their communist ideology.
So if the Flayer Will represents the KGB
then I guess Mike
represents the American CIA
because he figures out
that if they sedate Will,
it'll keep the Mind Flayer
from being able to spy on them.
This is basically like
unplugging the webcam.
The Mind Flayer could no
longer see into their lives.
So the gang is able to escape the lab.
Well, most of them.
When Will comes to,
he finds himself in
another unfamiliar location
because he does not know where he is,
neither does the Mind Flayer.
That is until Will hears
the Byers' phone ring
and realizes he's close to home.
Before the Mind Flayer can
send any monsters their way,
he's once again sedated and relocated.
When Will and effectively
the Mind Flayer inside of him
wake up they're being
blasted with heat lamps.
For the first time
Will's appearance changes
and his face and body are
covered with a blue veins
which kind of looks similar
to what the underground tunnels look like.
As Nancy jabs a hot fire
poker into Will's side
because, yes Nancy is
the type of girl to stab
at 1000 degree fire poker
into her boyfriend's
13-year-old brother in a moment of panic.
The Mind Flayer comes shooting out of Will
faster than a Halloween retailer
out of an empty storefront
on November 1st.
Right as this happens, Eleven
and Hopper are in place
at the Hawkins lab, and
using all of her strength
and being overpowered and
stuff, Eleven closes the gate.
Cutting off the Mind Flayer's
access to the Right Side Up.
The Demogorgons aren't able
to survive without their host,
but Will, now free of the Mind Flayer,
is cool to see another day.
But if we know anything
about the actual personality
of the Mind Flayer,
it's that this MF has
an appetite for revenge.
First, it was the flame
through our mercenaries,
but now its sites would be set on Eleven
for cutting off its access
to the Right Side Up.
And it has every intention
of making her pay
when the gate is reopened in 1985.
In the arms race of the 1980s,
the Russians were competing
with the Americans in many things
which included going to space
and to developing weapons.
That's the part that wasn't
recorded in the history books
was that this arms race also included
finding a way into this
newly discovered realm
that we know as the Upside Down.
They too wanted to open the gates,
but instead of using a middle school-aged,
Carrie White wannabe or project MK Ultra,
they went about it in the
most Russian way possible
with a giant nuclear drill
which was hidden under
the new Starcourt Mall.
In late June, the Russians
succeeded at opening the gate
advertently or inadvertently,
letting the Mind Flayer in once again,
this time with a new plan
and a desire to get back at Eleven.
Instead of using Demogorgons,
Demowogs, Demofrogs,
Demohogs, or Demodogs
for its demolition of
all things democratical,
it demonstrates its adaptability.
Realizing that it would be
more effective to flay people
and develop an army of human bodies
as opposed to growing an army of its own.
It uses the abandoned
Brimborn Steel Works warehouse
as its primary location and
decidedly more human accessible
safe house than the underground tunnels
which would make it easier
to lure in human victims.
It begins making its come back
by infecting an army of rats
who congregate at the
Steel Works and explode
after eating the wrong combination
of hazardous materials.
It's a whole thing.
The sludge from their guts
and tissues comes together
and it takes on a physical
form of organic matter
which serves as the new physical
body for the Mind Flayer.
Remember, every time we've seen
the Mind Flayer before this,
it's just made up of
these floating particles.
So this is most likely the first time
that it has a physical form.
The Mind Flayer is no longer picky
about who its first
human victim needs to be.
Literally, just the
first person to drive by
will be just fine.
Unfortunately, for Billy
Hargrove his late night MILF call
ends up being more
of a facial penetration event.
As he's dragged into the Steel Works
by the malevolent creature.
Billy ends up with the same
connection to the Mind Flayer
that we'll had a year prior.
Being able to think its
thoughts and feel its feelings.
It also communicates directly with him
by presenting a darker version of himself
that speaks to him.
The Mind Flayer's impact on
Billy is immediately noticeable.
When Billy is out in the
daytime, he's sweating profusely
and almost looks sick.
His skin even starts to burn
when exposed to the sun too much.
When Karen Wheeler tries to apologize
for standing Billy up the night before
he sees a version of himself
smashing her into a wall,
probably as a result of the
Mind Flayer being active.
Instead of going through with this,
Billy overrides the Mind Flayer
and tells Karen to stay away from him,
probably for the better.
As Billy tries to cool
off in a cold shower
and one of his killer life
guards, Heather Holloway,
checks in on him.
She asks if he's okay,
but what Billy hears
is something different.
HEATHER: Take me to him.
- But this time Billy
is unable to go against
the Mind Flayer's wishes.
(dramatic music)
(quirky music)
Heather next comes to
as she's being carried through
the Steel Works by Billy
who is under control of the Mind Flayer,
he lays her down on the floor
in an almost ceremonious
way and whispers to her.
BILLY: Don't be afraid.
It'll be over soon.
Just stay very still.
(Heather screaming)
- She doesn't.
As the Mind Flayer is... flaying?
...it notices Eleven using
her powers to spy on Billy
and is able to vanish from her sight.
The Mind Flayer spreads the
new victims from host to host
similar to a virus.
This means that its spread is
not dependent on Billy alone.
An older woman in town, Doris Driscoll,
notices that she has rats in her basement
and that they're acting very strange,
being aggressive and eating fertilizer.
She believes them to be diseased,
but eventually just like the
rats at Brimborn Steel Works,
her rats explodes allowing
the Mind Flayer to materialize
and infect her.
As Mrs. Driscoll was driven
towards the hospital,
she reaches out for the Steel Works
as the ambulance passes by it
indicating that she wants to join
the source of the Mind Flayer.
We never see if the rats are responsible
for infecting anyone else,
but we do see flayed Billy
and flayed Heather sitting down to dinner
with Heather's parents
eventually knocking them out as well,
taking them to Brimborn Steel Works
and bestowing them at the same fate.
(monster expectorates)
"IN THE FACE!"
"IN THE FAAACE!"
Once again, the flayed
looks sweaty and awful.
I mean rough day at the office, dude?
The Mind Flayer does its best
to keep its human hosts cool
to combat the summer heat.
It certainly doesn't help
when Billy is lured by Eleven
and her friends into a sauna at the pool.
They lock him in and crank up the heat
in their effort to expel the Mind Flayer.
As Billy writhes around in pain,
the Mind Flayer's hive
mind is still active,
making Mrs. Driscoll have a similar,
but somewhat more hilarious
reaction over at the hospital.
(Doris screaming)
So the Mind Flayer takes over Billy
making him smash his way through the door,
which kind of makes me
think that the Mind Flayer
somehow makes him even stronger.
Billy is a pretty strong dude
who spends his free time pumping iron,
but he literally bends
and destroys a metal pipe.
I mean, that's pretty impressive,
but I guess we've seen stranger things.
(crowd applauding)
Billy's escape causes Eleven
to have a throw down against him.
And while she is able to save her friends
the battle leaves her collapsed
on the floor in tears.
But as the Mind Flayer returns
to Brimborn Steel Works,
flayed Billy expresses to flayed Heather
that this fight was just as hard on him.
HEATHER: The girl was it, her was her?
BILLY: Yeah, it was her.
She knows now, she knows about me.
She could have killed me.
HEATHER: Yes, but not us.
Not us.
- Billy and Heather are more concerned
about the collective whole of
the Mind Flayer's influence
rather than their own
individual wellbeing.
This sentiment is not that far off
from the ideas promoted by
Soviet Union propaganda.
Red army posters advertised slogans
that perpetuated the idea
that everyone together is
better than the individual.
The idea is also reflected in the manner
in which the hive mind operates.
The Mind Flayer can perceive the thoughts
and feelings of any of the
organisms that is flayed,
but Will, Billy and the other victims
aren't necessarily given
any information in return.
Just like the KGB might
encourage Russian citizens
to report suspicions of
anticommunist behavior
while still keeping its main agenda,
a secret from the public.
In the case of the Mind Flayer,
it was building something
big in the shadows
as the 4th of July approached.
In the meantime, more people start to see
the creature's physical form.
After Jonathan Byers and Nancy Wheeler
fight off the flayed Hawkins
Post newspaper employees,
they break down into sludge
just like the rats from the Steel Works,
and the material is added
to the monster's body.
Nancy tries to escape and lock herself
in an empty room at the hospital,
but the Mind Flayer's
ability to turn itself
into a gelatinous elementary
school cafeteria food form
allows it to leak through the cracks,
but before she can be added
to the ranks of the flayed,
Eleven shows up in air
yeets that MF into the wall.
It's actually one of the best
air yeets I think we've seen.
After then getting air
yeeted out the window,
I think the Mind Flayer realizes
that it's no match for Eleven
when she's at full strength
and retreats into a storm drain.
Certainly not the first time
I've analyzed a creature
that utilizes a sewer system
to terrorize a small town.
Presumably there are more unknown victims
that become flayed.
A news report at the end of states
that 30 people died in a
fire at the Starcourt Mall
which is probably a government coverup
for what really went on there.
I'm guessing these 30 people represent
all of the victims of the Mind Flayer.
They would include Doris, Billy, Heather,
Heather's mom and dad, and to
Bruce from the Hawkins Post
which means there are
probably 24 other victims
throughout Hawkins.
That also makes it clear
what the Mind Flayer means
when it repeatedly talks
about building something.
Like when Eleven infiltrates Billy's mind
try to find the source of the corruption
and accidentally pulls the Mind Flayer
or at least the flayed
portion of Billy's brain
into her own head space.
BILLY: You let us in
and now you are going
to have to let us stay.
Don't you see? All this
time we've building it,
we've been building it for you.
- If this is the case,
it shows that the Mind
Flayer is kind of insane,
and this whole thing was
basically a revenge plot.
Before this, I kind of assumed that
this was like a world domination
sort of thing, but no,
the Mind Flayer is still pissed
about Eleven closing the gate.
I guess the lesson to be learned here
is don't go after someone else's dogs.
That's not cool.
MIKE: I have a feeling that
really pissed them off.
- As Eleven escapes the
grasp of the Mind Flayer
within the world of her own mind,
it had already summoned
everyone that had been flayed
sending them to the Brimborn Steel Works
where they're broken down
into the dark sludge material
and absorbed into the
stature of the Mind Flayer.
Which explains how it was able to grow
from a roughly seven foot
tall monster at the hospital
to basically a 16 foot big
boy by Independence Day.
And as with any good
Independence Day celebration,
there were about to be some fireworks.
MAYOR KLINE: Who here wants
to see some fireworks?
(crowd cheers)
(upbeat music)
(suspenseful music)
While most of Hawkins was distracted
and enamored by the
colorful fireworks display
at the 4th of July carnival,
the Mind Flayer was busy making
more moves in the shadows.
Having used Eleven's
own tactic against her
by stepping into her mind.
It now knew her location
and was hungry for a rematch
using its new, more powerful body.
Another big showdown occurs,
and although Eleven is
able to, once again,
get the upper hand by dismembering
two of the creatures orfices,
it nearly captures her after
dragging her by the ankle.
And she's only able to
escape, thanks to Nancy
who shoots the Mind Flayer.
"In the face!"
- Eleven wards off the creature
by using what appears to be
the full force of her powers
to split his head into two even
if only temporarily, however
the bite on her leg leaves
her in tremendous pain.
The kids escape to the mall
where Eleven passes out,
and it's revealed that a slug,
just like the one that will
coughed up on Christmas in 1983,
is moving around inside her leg.
She's eventually able to
excruciatingly remove it,
but it seems that it may
have accomplished its mission
anyways, because after this
Eleven loses her powers.
At this point, we don't
know with 100% certainty
how this Demowog left behind in her leg.
might've contributed to the hampering
of her telekinesis, but let's
look at what we do know.
Eleven's powers have never been unlimited.
The more telekinetic,
heavy lifting she does,
the bigger the nosebleed
she gets as a result.
So we can conclude that her powers
are somehow related to
her circulatory system.
When the will was infected,
he became very sick
and required many hospital
and lab visits to recover.
Seeing as how the slug was
moving around inside of El,
I'm guessing that it was able
to infect her bloodstream
which may be the reason
she's no longer able to
call upon her telekinesis.
Billy, locates the kids at the mall
and alerts the Mind
Flayer of their location.
It shows up and crashes
through the glass ceiling
above the food court,
then using its long arms,
searches the mall,
probably looking for Eleven
or anyone else it can flay.
Despite not being able to rely
on Eleven's powers this time,
the kids still managed
to almost outsmart it
by using a litany of sounds,
including the engine of Jonathan's car
to lure it's away from Eleven
and everyone else at the mall.
But this ruse only goes so far,
as Billy witnesses Max and Mike
trying to help Eleven out of the mall,
and sermons the Mind Flayer
back to her location.
Without her telekinesis,
Billy has a much easier
time defeating Eleven
and brings her back to the food court,
offering her to his master
in an almost ceremonious way
as we've seen him do to
others at the Steel Works.
He even gives the same warning.
BILLY: Don't be afraid.
It will be over soon.
Just try and stay very still
- But El's friends still
have one last trick
and it is an explosive one.
As we know the Mind
Flayer doesn't like heat,
so the fireworks that Mike and Lucas
stole from a grocery store earlier
end up being an ideal
weapon to fight back with.
They engage in a huge battle,
really dealing some major
hits on the Mind Flayer,
in order to protect Eleven.
Now, throughout the video,
I've explained to many
of the different ways
that this monster
represents the communist
ideals of the USSR.
So the fact that our American heroes
use 4th of July fireworks, a
literal image of USA patriotism
and democracy to fight the creature,
is the perfect symbol for
the '80s political subtext
that has been running over and under
the first three seasons
of "Stranger Things."
But ultimately these
efforts are only enough
to slow the Mind Flayer down.
The final blow, so to speak,
ironically comes from the
monster's greatest servant,
Billy Hargrove, who gets
a little bit of control
over his own body back
after Eleven enters his mind
and reminds him of his childhood.
Billy takes a stand
against the Mind Flayer
and sacrifices himself
to protect his sister
and her friends long
enough for Joyce Byers
to get to the gates to the Upside Down.
Like the Russian scientist, Alexi,
who was executed for
aiding his American friends
earlier that day,
the mind Flayer no longer
has any use for Billy.
And he becomes a victim
of its metaphorical,
capital punishment.
However, he would be its final victim.
As the closing of the gate
causes the creature to
immediately shut down and die.
But while this was the end
of the elementary school
cafeteria lunch meat
version of the MF,
we would see the original
shadow monster form
looking over rural America again.
That's right.
I'm talking about Rocket League.
(car engine revving)
(upbeat music)
In 2019 during a good old
classic game of League,
the farmstead was thrown
into a perpetual state
of Upside Down and the
Mind Flayer appeared
for the first time in many years.
It seems by now the Mind Flayer
has pretty much forgotten about Eleven
and just looms over the farmstead
and takes in some good
old games of soccer.
Now, I know some of you
are going to try to say
that Rocket League isn't part
of "Stranger Things Canon,"
but really I imagine Rocket
League takes place so many years
after 1985, that it would
really be difficult to say
that Mike, Lucas, Will and Dustin
do not eventually turn into
these little egg characters.
I mean, look, you can see
Chief Hopper right there.
So I don't really see anything
to suggest that Rocket League
is not canon here.
Not sure about "Dead
By Daylight" though...
If you wanna see the histories
of more stranger things characters,
click that playlist on the left.
And if you love horror,
remember to subscribe to
CZsWorld for new horrors
every week,
ring the death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one,
assuming we both survive.
(upbeat music)